[Music]
this was
an experiment tag you were it
no one had ever seen anything like it i
wanted
to capture the family foreign
[Music]
but i don't think any of us sat there
thinking
oh my god we're changing the world
[Music]
joan had a brilliantly simple notion
children were watching a tremendous
amount of television
so why not see if it could educate them
i love the whole idea of taking
commercial
techniques and applying them to a show
for kids
i was convinced that it would be
impossible to do
jim henson frank oz if they were on you
had a good day
with the best of friends yes how many
lines do you have
three three while trying to get the
first one
better
i had become intellectually and
spiritually
involved with the civil rights movement
those were
revolutionary times i saw it as a
political show
there's no question that we're
integrated that's our worst sin i'm
happy to be a sinner beautiful children
will grow up
to be on the set watching this dynamic
it was magic
it was people dedicated to a real ideal
and having the will to do it it was
almost having the time of our lives
writing silly things but always with
this message
that television could be socially
[Music]
valuable
we're not sure what we are or what we
can be we know there's potential and the
realization to
accept ourselves that's what sesame
street's about
[Music]
you